ايديكم ويخزهم وينصركم عليهم ويشفي صدور
قوم مؤمنين صدق الله العظيم انتصارا
لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني وضمن الرد على
العدوان الامريكي البريطاني على بلدنا تم
الاشتباك اليوم مع عدد مع عدد من المدمرات
والسفن الحربيه الامريكيه في خليج عدن
وباب المندب اثناء قيام تلك السفن بتقديم
الحمايه لسفينه تجاريتين
امريكيتين وكان من نتائج عمليه الاشتباك
ما يلي اصابه سفينه حربيه امريكيه اصابه
مباشره اجبار السفينتين التجاريتين
الامريكيتين على التراجع والعوده وصول عدد
من صواريخنا البالستيه الى اهدافها رغم
محاوله السفن الحربيه اعتراضها هذا وقد
استخدمت القوات المسلحه اليمنيه في عمليه
الاشتباك التي استمرت لاكثر من ساعتين
عددا من الصواريخ
البالستيه ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد
استمرارها في منع الملاحه الاسرائيليه او
المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله في
البحرين الاحمر والعربي حتى وقف العدوان
ورفع الحصار عن الشعب الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه وتؤكد القوات المسلحه اليمنيه على
اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات العسكريه اللازمه
ضمن حق الدفاع المشروع عن بلدنا وشعبنا
وامتنا وذلك في استهداف كافه الاهداف
المعاديه الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في البحرين الاحمر والعربي
والله حسبنا ونعم الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم
النصير عاش اليمن حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر
لليمن ولكل احرار الامه صنعاء الث عش من
رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق لل 24 من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه